with respect to the economic crisis in
the financial crisis of the past couple
of years we're concentrating at Davos
and working with the the other g20
countries and making sure that we are in
agreement on continuing stimulus for the
next year because the economic recovery
is modest and there's a lack of evidence
of firm private sector demand returning
so we need to continue the public second
demand which is through the stimulus
program not only in Canada but in the
other the other g20 countries we're also
looking at avoiding this kind of crisis
in the future or minimizing the impact
of it by a mutual assessment process
which is designed to be be done by the
International Monetary Fund it with have
discussions here today but the best
design of that will follow up those
discussions with discussions in
kollywood Nunavut of g7 finance
ministers and bank governors from the g7
countries next weekend and then at the
g20 meetings at Muskoka and Toronto in
June this year so we have a lot of work
to do on the financial regulation side
and the reform of financial institutions
in the g20 which is now the premier
forum for financial economic discussions
in the world whilst were to do to get
ready for the meeting in June name is
Roger